and you know um
i um
my father
is a prime example of
the thing that i was supposed to avoid
essentially
um
i don't know my father since i was like
my father left me and my mom when i was
one year old
and
my mom always told me that
he was allowed to always like be part of
my life even if he wasn't part of her
life
and she was expecting him to do so but
he just wasn't when i was like i don't
know like uh four or five years old i
got like um
a cheap
toy
motorcycle
um and then i
that was it that was like the one time i
heard
from him until i was like 16.
um and then
he met me just
so that he can give me my signature so i
can change my name
um and after that change it to his name
didn't change it to my mom's family name
right i was on his name um and and then
he was like
he beat he bit himself in the chest with
his fist like oh i want to buy you a
guitar or something like that i want to
spend more time with you and i'm like
i don't believe that but you know i'm
gonna stay quiet see what you're gonna
do that never happened again
uh again i haven't heard from him since
i was like fair enough now
funnily enough i actually had um a
message from my mom saying your dad's
been looking for you and i'm like
look i'm 31 years old now
i've achieved more in my life
that than he achieved in his i i know
i know how he ended up i'm not curious
to be part of his life and i was like
i'm not interested
i think
i think that my mom was a better role
model a better masculine role model for
me than my dad could ever been
are you saying
that your mother had to fulfill that
role she had to she had no choice right
because um
otherwise but in the ideal world you
would have preferred it to be him
no
i would have preferred it to be someone
else that has a bit of
cojones
yeah you know a bit more responsibility
look at me i'm 31 years old i don't have
a child
because i've been responsible i've been
i've been engaging in sexual activities
responsibly
i've been protecting myself you know
like
i'm not married because i haven't found
the right person you know i'm not
jumping in
you know willy-nilly into
whatever situation just you know so i
can be a father
i'm waiting for the right moment and i
feel like
he's made all the mistakes that he could
have possibly made
and
and he was a role model for me in terms
of what not to do
right
so when it's time for you to become a
father you know what not to do
yes right
if somehow by accident let's say uh
unlikely but by accident i have a kid
i just i guess i have to just drop
everything it's not about my life
anymore you know i can talk from
personal experience because i share the
same sentiments as you because i was
raised without my father and um he was
he disappointed me and he had like five
children that he disappointed so it
wasn't just me um
but what it done to me is that it made
me understand what i don't want to be
like but a lot of the times when it
comes to fatherhood and children who
don't have fathers
is that they turn out just like their
fathers they do the same things you know
they repeat the same cycles that their
father did so i just commend you on that
so
you know well done keep going just just
to say
this is
this is an example like just because my
father was like that doesn't mean that
society should look down on fathers as a
whole you know because then you instill
that sentiment
and then
men
think like oh well everyone else is
doing it you know
why are you looking at me for and and
that gives them the opportunity to
for them to be irresponsible
we should encourage people we should
like um
we should encourage like fathers like we
should we should see fatherhood the same
way as we see motherhood because then we
avoid all these problems you know
because i'll read something uh because
in 2020
2020 there were 15.3
million children
in the united states with
a single mother without a father in
their life
and the amount of single fathers there
were
is 3.2 million
so single motherhood like when i asked a
question before like do mothers you know
get seen as the better parent if a child
do you say something
yeah if a child does get into a
situation where he has to go with one of
the parents it's normally the mother
that they go with well women are
incentivized to do that because they get
more child support if they get if the
father gets less custody
and so like we'll complain all day about
men not being in you know the kids lives
or whatever
um and not not yours was a different
situation but like we're literally
paying women to not to get the father
out of the home
even even i had um auntie on here auntie
jenny yeah and she was saying how like
back in her day that if they the girls
wanted to move out of the house they'd
just get pregnant because the government
would give him a apartment is that a
good way to bring a child into the world
and it honestly just speaks to like
women nowadays
you know
my mom told me
my dad
did not give any sort of money no no
alamo no nothing you know and um i was
thinking about it like [ __ ] if something
happens if i inherit something you know
because at the end of the day he was my
father
what should i do and and i came to the
conclusion out of integrity i have to
refuse it i have to refuse anything that
that man gives me
because that that then it means
that like i'm just
just unable unable to to make my own
future without you know without him like
out of principle you've you haven't been
there i don't need your
you know
what are you doing i don't know you know
i would take it yeah
so it depends
nothing that he could give me
would be enough
for me to justify
giving away my integrity
he's not successful so how would it how
how has it sorry affected you
not having your father around it it's
been hard because i
i didn't as a child i didn't know how to
be masculine
um i would get beaten up bullied a lot
at school i i would be afraid to fight
back i had the
glass
made of glass syndrome you know i was
afraid that if i
if i punch something someone like
they would just shatter because
i don't know like i just
was not taught to defend myself
my mom
you know
she couldn't really
educate me and on that side of stuff so
it definitely had an impact on me i had
to i had to learn
everything i had to learn from the
streets
i had to
go through the hard bits you know
get robbed get beaten up um
and and
it was a grueling grueling situation
but uh i think i came out of it
quite well and quite um
it could have been worse i could have
come out real
i think your story is you know one of
the reasons why we say fathers are so
important you know um i think society
pushes fathers out of the home if you go
to the um
fathers for justice website it shows
that 200 children per day are removed
from their
father
by the family court system
so i think the society doesn't really
value
fatherhood for so many fathers to be
removed and i think it's very easy
for they pay you yeah they pay you to do
it
so you're literally paid out to be a
single mother so i have i have two
points to make the first one is um all
children born uncivilized someone has to
civilize these children so if you're two
people who are drug addicts then you can
conceive a child is it irresponsible of
you to conceive a child in the
circumstances you are or is it unfair on
the child okay if you're if you
i'm gonna just do them one at a time so
you said if you're both drug addicts
yeah it's irresponsible to have a child
i would agree yeah okay so we all know
where that's gonna go with the child
when they're conceived right yeah we all
know anomaly happens i don't want to be
an anomaly
okay and where i work i get to see a lot
of birth certificates
and
my life is social experiments in general
so i pick up on little things a lot of
single mothers don't have their father's
names on the birth certificate of their
child
i'm i'm sorry if i'm a father i want to
see my name on that we do i'm sorry what
are you doing where's my name on that
that is my child
like how disrespectful that what do you
think of this man that just inseminated
you and then you conceived the child and
then you don't even put his name on it
yeah are you like serious because men
are not respected yeah and who is that
well i also think it's like they say
it's a form of hypergamy because the
girl doesn't want to be associated with
that man's last name she's like because
that's not the best she could do you're
happy to have sex and get your vagina
filled up i didn't say it's a good i
didn't just say i didn't say i
recommended it i'm just like i'm adding
this to people someone are raising these
people like this yeah somebody's raising
this consistent cycle because
if you grow up in a household where mom
and dad are married they are presenting
you the examples of relationship between
two people who raising children and if
you have a good good relationship with
your mom and your dad or whatever you
think is you tend to adopt those
relationships and take into your life as
an adult
most women who have a great relationship
with their fathers they tend to bond
with men most of the time and once men
have a good relationship with their
mothers they tend to have a good
relationship with females along the way
especially if the environment they're in
isn't violent abusive
drug related it's it's you don't need to
be millionaire you don't need to be
extremely educated basic level of
parenting
provides that
as many of you know i was just banned on
tic tac and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible